دائرة الحرب تدور والخطر يجوب
العالم. العالم ينقسم الى اطراف
متعددة. فما هذا الذي يجري?
شظايا وجراح الحرب تتوسع اكثر
فاكثر. وها هو نزيفها يقترب من
المنطقة العربية. فما شأن العرب
بهذه الحرب? انها الحرب العالمية
يا سادة. التي ستدخل الى كل دولة
والى كل بيت. ولن يقف احد في
مدرجات المشجعين. الكل سيشترك.
واصوات ضجيج العسكرية تصل الى
الدول العربية. موسكو والغرب على
كتفي الميزان. لترجح كفة احدهما.
لكن اذا اشتعلت حرب عالمية فهذه
هي الدول العربية التي ستقاتل مع
بوتين لتقف ضد امريكا. الجزائر.
هنا ابناء عبدالمجيد تبون لا
يلعبون. الميزانية العسكرية
تتضاعف الى ثلاثة اضعافها.
والدليفير الروسي لا يتوقف عن مد
الجزائر اسلحة. وفي الضفة الاخرى
الدول العربية تتودد للجزائر
والهدف رائحة الغاز. الكل يبحث
عن الطاقة تحضيرا لحرب لا تنطفئ
نارها ولا ينقطع دخانها. ولكن
مهلا بل ان الجزائر قد تعلن عن
نفسها كطرف في الحرب لاشعال حفلة
الانتقام. والتي لا زالت تشتعل
في صدور الجزائريين الى هذه
اللحظة والهدف اخذ الثأر. لاكثر
من مليون ونصف المليون شهيد
سقطوا ضحايا الاحتلال وفرنسا احد
الاطراف الاساسية للكفة الغربية.
هناك يسيل لعاب الجزائر وشعبها
لاخذ انتقامهم. فالفرصة مواتية
والانتقام طعام يطبخ على نار
هادئة. ويتذوق حلاوته اكثر من
يتركه ليبرد اكثر. ولا ننسى تلك
الاراضي التي كانت جزءا من ماضي
فرنسا الاسود. التي التهمتها
نيران التجارب النووية الفرنسية
لتذيب ارواح اكثر من اربعين الف
جزائري بين ومصاب بامراض سرطانية
وتشوهات خلقية. وفي اخر زيارة
للرئيس الفرنسي ماكرون رفض ان
يقدم الاعتذار للشعب الجزائري عن
كل تلك الجرائم ضد الانسانية.
الا تستحون يا هؤلاء? وهل ينسى
الجزائر كل هذا ليقف مع حلف
الناتو التي فرنسا عضو فيه
وليقاتل الجندي الجزائري
والفرنسي في خندق واحد? ام سيقف
مع روسيا التي مدتهم بالاسلحة
المتطورة والغواصات النووية
الحربية ونقصد هنا سو سبعة
وخمسين. ولا نعلم الى هذه اللحظة
ماذا تخفي احشاء المخازن
الجزائرية من السلاح الروسي.
لتحتل الجزائر بهذه الاسلحة
المرتبة السادسة والعشرين على
المستوى العالمي. وفي المرتبة
الثانية افريقيا والثالثة كاقوى
جيش عربي. لنوجه هذا السؤال الى
الجمهور اي صف سيختار ابناء
الجزائر? الجمهورية المصرية.
هناك حقيقة يجهلها البعض. سلاح
الجيش المصري كله سلاح امريكي.
لكن هذا لا يعني ان مصر في كفة
الامريكان. فهناك عدد من الاسلحة
وعلى رأسها طائرة اف خمسة عشر.
رفضت الولايات المتحدة الموافقة
على اعطائها لمصر. هذا الامر جعل
القاهرة تفكر مليا في تنويع
مصادر السلاح. ليتجه المصريون
نحو الجانب الروسي لعقد صفقة
المقاتلات الروسية سوخوي خمسة
وثلاثين. وتضمن الاتفاق بوصول
اثني عشر طائرة خلال العام الفين
واثنين وعشرين. ثم بحث وصول اثني
عشر طائرة اخرى خلال الفين
وثلاثة وعشرين. ليكون الاجمالي
اربعة وعشرين طائرة بالاضافة الى
الخمس المسلمة قبل ذلك. ولكن
مهلا فكل هذا ليس دافعا لتقف مصر
ضد امريكا وحلف الناتو. فمصر لن
تنسى اربعة وسبعين عاما من
الاحتلال الانجليزي. ذاق فيها
المصريون مرارة الاحتلال. حيث
كانت احكام الاعدام وقف فيها
المصريون بالطوابير الطويلة. فلم
يرحم الانجليز فيها لا النساء
ولا الشيوخ ولا الاطفال. لينفض
المصريون غبارهم ويجتثوا هذا
الاحتلال. واضف على ذلك حفلة
العدوان الثلاثي على مصر. والتي
شاركت فيها بريطانيا وفرنسا
واسرائيل. وكل هذه الدول حليفة
لامريكا. فهل يترك المصريون كل
هذا جانبا? ليتحالف مع الغربيين
بعيدا عن اليد الروسية. سنترك
الاجابة على هذا السؤال المصري.
المملكة العربية السعودية. بعيدا
عن قضية الصحفي خاشقجي التي تبتز
بها امريكا السعودية لتنفر
المملكة من الطرف الغربي نحو
الطرف الروسي. ومنذ بدء الغزو
الروسي لاوكرانيا سعت امريكا مع
الاتحاد الاوروبي الى دفع
السعودية لضخ نفط اكثر بالاسواق
والى منع الامارات من استقبال
يخوت الاوليجرش الروس واموالهم
ولكن دون نجاح. بيد انه بات جليا
ان الخليج خاصة السعودية
والامارات. تتردد في الوقوف الى
جانب واشنطن اذ لا تزال تلتزم
بحصص انتاج تحالف. بقيادة
السعودية وروسيا فضلا عن استمرار
استقبال الامارات لليقوت
العملاقة المملوكة للاوليكرش
الروس. ولم يتوقف الامر عند هذا
الحد. بل رفضت دول الحليفة
للولايات المتحدة في الشرق
الاوسط لا سيما العراق والاردن
وحتى الكيان الاسرائيلي التصويت
ضد روسيا في مجلس الامن الدولي.
العراق. العراق الجارح الذي عاثت
قوات الولايات المتحدة في اراضيه
فسادا وقتلت وشردت ودمرت وابادا.
وحولت حياة العراقيين من رغد
العيش الى شظف ومعاناة الحياة.
فضلا عن اكثر من مليون شهيد
قدمهم العراق ضحايا للغزو
الامريكي الظالم. ولا ننسى علاقة
القيادات العراقية في الوقت
الحالي. والاكثر قربا من النظام
الايراني. ومرة اخرى ان ايران
حليف اساسي للدب وليس حبا في
الروس وانما كرها وغيظا لما تركه
الاحتلال الامريكي من اثار على
نفوس العراقيين. وبعد ان اعدم
الامريكان الرئيس العراقي السابق
صدام حسين فاين سيضع العراقيون
ثقلهم? وكالعادة نترك الاجابة
لاسود الرافدين. اليمن وسوريا.
ما ان اعلن الرئيس الروسي
الاعتراف باستقلال اقليمي دونتسك
ولوجنسك الانفصاليين حتى سارع
الرئيس السوري الاسد لدعم قرار
بوتين والاعتراف بهما كاراض
روسية. ولم يكن ذلك مفاجئا.
فالدعم الروسي يلعب دورا رئيسيا
في الحفاظ على استمرار النظام
السوري منذ عام الفين واحد عشر.
لتنضم سوريا لقائمة الحلفاء
العرب لروسيا في السلم والحرب.
اما اليمن الذي يمتلك احد اهم
المضائق في العالم. نعم انه مضيق
باب المندب الذي جعل الامريكان
يدعمون دول الخليج لشن حرب على
اليمن على المضيق. وبعد ثمان
سنوات من الحرب والحصار لن ينضم
اليمن الى الكفة الغربية حتما.
وسيكون طريقه سالكا نحو الطرف
الروسي. والسبب ان روسيا تقود
محادثات سرية لتصلح بين ايران
والسعودية بحسب صحيفة نيويورك
تايمز. ليكتمل الحلف وتبسط موسكو
ذراعها على باب المندب الذي
يسيطر على اكثر من اثني عشر
بالمائة من التجارة العالمية.
فضلا عن جماعة الحوثي المقربة من
ايران. والتي تسيطر خمسين بالمئة
من الاراضي اليمنية. ولنكررها
مرة اخرى ان ايران الحليف الاقرب
لبوتين. عندما جاء الغربيون الى
الجزائر لتمدهم بالطاقة رفضت.
وعندما اتجهوا نحو قطر اعلنها
وزير الطاقة القطري بقوله لا
تستطيع دولة بمفردها تعويض هذا
الكم من الغاز الذي تصدره روسيا
ونحن ملتزمون بعقود ليترك العرب
الغرب يلهثون وراء الطاقة. اما
تجارة الاسلحة الروسية لها دون
شك دور في حسم مواقف الدول
العربية. اذ عملت موسكو خلال
السنوات الاخيرة على استعادة
مكانتها في دول عربية كان لها
نفوذ فيها في الحقبة السوفيتية
واعتمدت على تجارة الاسلحة بشكل
كبير لتحقق هذا الهدف. برأيكم هل
العرب اقرب الى روسيا في حال
اندلاع حرب عالمي